all right great thanks everyone this is
exposing dark data in the enterprise
with custom NLP so before we get started
I just want to say you know one of my
favorite things about coming to these
conferences is just to kind of see the
experience that we're all kind of going
through as data scientists and really
kind of to see what other people are
doing how they're approaching similar
types of problems and then come and kind
of you know take bits and pieces of that
incorporate that into my own solution
and so that's really what I hope to do
today for you guys is just to kind of
share some of the some of the challenges
that I've been working through some of
my approaches to those challenges and
then hopefully when you guys go back to
work on Monday you can take some of
those and incorporate that into what
you're doing so with that said you know
I do want to say that I do not have the
magical solution for NOP pipelines yeah
I'd be a little bit skeptical of anyone
who said they did I mean the bottom line
is is that human language is very
complex humans are very complex and so
mm-hmm
with that said you know these are just
some approaches that I like to do so a
little bit a little bit about my
background 2012 I started working on my
first commercial product in 2014 I
commercialized my first my first product
and that was a document management
system aimed at digitizing data assets
for four different enterprises wasn't
too heavy in any hardcore NOP there were
some fuzzy matching there was a very
strong OCR component but in terms of
some of the advance NOP concepts also
necessarily incorporated yet and then in
2017 commercialized my first true NOP
product immediately started panicking
said there's no way I'm doing this right
went back to school to study felt a
little bit better it did make some
changes in some upgrades but overall
these are just kind of some of the
lessons I've picked up along the way and
just some of the scar tissue as well so
today mm-hmm I'm really gonna talk about
a couple things
first NLP is a two-part problem the
first part which is the whole modeling
component I think is something that
we're all very familiar with the other
major component is
especially in the enterprise especially
dealing with dark data is feature
extraction which is pretty much part of
feature engineering and this is a
component that really outs you know out
especially in academia does not really
get a whole lot of love and attention
it's kind of like Cinderella that you
know it's ignored but it's extremely
important especially when you're dealing
with dark data so mm-hmm
most of the time and what I mean by dark
data and enterprise is it's very rare in
some enterprises have this but most
enterprises it's very rare for them to
actually have someone sitting down
annotating and structuring text for you
in many cases and in mainly situations
that I've worked in you know you're
basically just getting a document dump I
mean there's no annotations for entities
or intense or topics within any
documents there's no prior labels or
classifications that are given to you
it's basically just you know going in
and doing a lot of that feature
extraction on your own and so in it and
so anyway with with that said there's in
enterprises there's a very limited
amount of label data sometimes none at
all
there's domain-specific terminology
which I'll discuss more a second but
this is a this is another big one in
terms of you know adding some
constraints to what you can do with
commercially available software or open
source software is that you know there's
there's companies specific terms there's
product specific terms there's specific
terms within domains that are not openly
available and these are some things that
you have to kind of build yourself
another major component is grammar
spelling and syntax so a lot of times
especially when you're you know maybe
you're doing classwork or maybe you're
doing online tutorials the corpus that
you're analyzing are you know often
Wikipedia articles or news articles
things that are very eloquently written
things that are written by journalists
who have editors and other resources to
really create literature masterpieces
and the bottom line is in the real world
and a lot of enterprises people don't
write like that you've got many
different authors which means you have
many different vocabularies you have a
whole lot of different graham
and styles and a lot of times a lot of
that is really unreliable so there's
some additional steps additional
processing there that needs to happen
and then finally training availability
you know with with any kind of machine
learning project you know it does
require some domain and human expertise
to go in and train and that's almost
always going to be limited especially
when you get to more specific use cases
that expertise is very expensive and in
time-consuming to rely on and so really
kind of some of the approaches some of
the tips and tricks that I plan to share
today or really is a bit more of a
balanced approach so really
understanding a corpus you know some
ways to add domain knowledge and then
creating some flexible machine learning
processes so I'm just curious who here
has completed an MLP project or is an
NLP practitioner okay so a handful and I
know I'm not the first
NOP talk of this conference all oh I'll
do a quick little introduction and then
I'll and then I'll kind of jump right
into challenges in the enterprise some
of the things that I've come across and
then we'll go through a specific example
and then I'll also also demonstrate that
example as well so all right so what is
natural language processing and again I
know most most of you party already
already know this but it's basically
teaching machines to understand human
language and you know for the most part
pretty much everyone should have already
been dealing with this with you know
search engines like Google with virtual
assistants and chat BOTS so why is MLP
hard and really the way I like to
describe this to people is it's broken
up into two parts one it's very very
deceptive and misleading and two there's
a lot of information a lot of context
that's required to really understand it
and so the first part which is kind of
this idea of illusion and almost
deception can just as an example our
news headlines and so human language can
be very misleading with some of the
things that are said and can be
interpreted in multiple different ways
so for example teacher strikes idle kids
stolen painting found by tree and these
are real news headline
by the way hospitals are sued by seven
foot doctors kids make nutritious snacks
so anyway these are just these these are
a couple examples of the first part of
this quote and that you know human
language can be misleading and very you
know very deceptive the second the
second part of this quote is you know
basically what our eyes are what reality
what we can't really see and so this is
a very this is just a very simple
sentence very simple sentence structure
in fact most of the grammar the syntax
and vocabulary even stays constant
throughout these examples but they have
very very different relationships and
and really all we're doing is switching
out one word but here you can see
there's multiple different ways to eat
spaghetti and unless you're bringing in
outside context you really don't know
which way you're talking about just by
reading the text that you see in front
of you so those were just some very
simple examples to show that human
language is you know very very difficult
to understand and really what it comes
down to is that it's very very noisy now
we'll get to some more complicated
examples in a second but those are you
notice those are very very short pieces
of text so anyway the point is is that
before you get to any kind of modeling
it's really important to realize that
you have a noisy text you've got to pick
out the right features and that becomes
very very tricky and so so what I what
like what I want to do to kind of
visualize this is this is a very simple
NLP pipeline it's certainly you know
there's there's more things you can do
in terms of limitation there are certain
things you can switch around but this is
just a simple example and one of the
things that immediately jumps out is
that this is a very linear process so
basically you know what that means is if
you screw up in the beginning it's gonna
make the end screwed up as well so if
you cut if you look at this and want to
break this apart into components really
most of this is feature extraction
they'll you know basically all of these
prior steps which are in blue are to
extract out the features the variables
that you're trying to model
down streaming in the end so mm anyway
since this is a linear process I just
want to highlight that feature
extraction is very very important
especially when dealing with messy text
because it dictates two important things
down in your downstream modeling first
the more accurate your features that are
extracted the more accurate your
modeling is going to be if you're just
extracting noise and garbage and you try
to model noise and garbage and your
models are not going to be as accurate
the second thing is that when you
extract features ideally you're also
leaving out a lot of the garbage a lot
of the noise that's left in text and
what that does is that speeds up your
modeling as well as many of you know NOP
deals with very very sparse matrices and
some some processes downstream like
topic modeling can be very
computationally expensive especially to
get to things like hyper parameter
tuning mm-hmm and in running multiple
iterations through a model so that also
by extracting out features and leaving
at noise it also speeds up the speed of
your models so to kind of step through a
very very simple example Before we jump
into you know doing an enterprise this
is just a small project they did a
couple years ago this was on a very very
small scale very similar to stuff you've
probably already seen but basically
analyzing reviews and so for this
specific example this was for hotels
basically they wanted to analyze reviews
they had a whole bunch of different data
sources and they wanted to make some
strategic management decisions based off
of what their customers were saying now
they had a whole bunch of reviews that
they needed to analyze and really the
deliverable for this project was this
guest satisfaction scorecard so I'm I'm
a manager or I'm an owner of a hotel
what do I you know what am I good at
what am I not good at and similarly you
know in terms of terms of my competitors
you know where are they beating me what
you know what are they doing better than
I am so from a very high-level process
diagram this is you know this is pretty
much the whole this is pretty much the
NOP pipeline so basically you know
grabbing the text formatting it
processing it breaking
apart doing some very simple feature
extractions the only two features that
were extracted here were sentiment and
entities and then those entities were
mapped to a topic which were these these
were the topics down here and with those
topics basically they consisted of
entities those entities were tagged with
sentiment and then we were able to
produce that scorecard which I'll get to
in a second
so again this is a kind of a simple
example but in terms of NOP where do you
start well if it's very similar to any
kind of data analysis you start with
exploration and certainly there are a
lot of different options here I threw up
a couple here just to kind of to kind of
shotgun a couple but for example you can
do a lexical dispersion plot this kind
of just shows the instances of which a
certain entity or topic may appear
within a text so this is the book of
Genesis you can see Adam and Noah appear
in early on in the book of Genesis
Joseph appears at the end that's you
know this is just one simple technique
you can measure some descriptive
statistics like lexical diversity that
shows basically how frequently each word
appears and so if you've got a lot of
lexical diversity that means you've got
a very high high range in vocabulary
there are some other things as well and
if anyone is interested there's an
antique a tutorial that that I wrote
that kind of walks you through some of
these that it's pretty quick to do so
anyway this is kind of just a high-level
overview and again this is just a quick
example of a quick snapshot of what you
can do of your corpus you can capture
some high level statistics and again
there's some of the libraries I use down
there for sentiment analysis basically
what happened here was that based off of
those basically classifying each review
after POS or part of speech tagging what
you can do is you can basically pull out
the adjectives the descriptors and then
create a word cloud from these and then
finally like I was saying before map the
entities to a to a topic
in this case this is a scorecard and we
can see basically overall how this hotel
performs so this is a this is a simple
hotel review example that is again
pretty straightforward alright so let's
let's add a layer complexity here and
talked about the enterprise so in the
enterprise there's I guess there's
there's a couple more challenges and by
a couple more I mean a lot more and
these this is by no means an exhaustive
list these are just some common ones
that I that have have reoccurred and so
for the for with challenges that are
pertinent to this discussion I
highlighted a few that are very commonly
focused specifically around NLP in the
enterprise and things that I've come
across really I think the best way for
me to to address some of these is to
walk through an example and this is so
the example I'm going to walk through is
specifically for a very very large
enterprise in the oil and gas services
industry specifically what they were
looking for was an information retrieval
system so this is almost like it's I
don't want to say a search engine but
it's basically a search engine you asked
a question in natural language and then
it returns an answer found in the
documentation so the problem I guess the
problem is currently the way that they
do this basically have a customer the
customer calls and has an issue you know
typically the the the customer service
representative which is an operator or
technician or even an engineer will
start trying to troubleshoot the issue
and the problem is is that a lot of this
information is new to the customer
service representative so what happens
is that you know generally in these
types of physicians there can be high
turnover there can be some tribal
knowledge that's lost and basically what
happens is there's this whole finagle to
go and chase down the correct answer
there's a lot of discussions that are
happening between people and then even
the
and then even between those people you
know there's a lot of documentation
that's you know searched and and and
difficult to find now the this industry
has been around for a while
oil and gas has been around forever and
so there's already a lot of
documentation that that has that
knowledge captured inside the problem is
that knowledge is very very difficult to
find and it takes a very very long time
so in this in this case in this
information retrieval system whether
this company wanted it was really just
one person to chase down the issue and
basically they knew that hey we've got
this whole corpus of documentation that
has all these Diagnostics in it we just
need to be able to find it faster and so
hence this is why they wanted an
information retrieval system get that
information much faster so in terms of
you know approaching this problem first
you know before even getting to a
solution you know really trying to
understand the constraints of what the
of the problem and so like I mentioned
before this is dark data so it's
unstructured there's no previous
annotations this is basically just the
document dump and and what that does is
that's gonna limit a lot of the lot of
things you can do so you you know with
supervised machine learning there's some
limitations on that just because you
don't have as much labeled data now as
you acquire more you can incorporate
that more there's and then the other
thing is that there's some extra effort
needed for feature extraction meaning
that you know these documents these text
again they're not tagged with entities
you really don't know if some of these
documents even have any value whatsoever
and so you know there's kind of this
hyper focuses emphasis on making sure
that you're extracting the right
features for your modeling downstream
and then you also need to understand
your corpora so this gets really tricky
because in the enterprise again you've
got multiple authors they've got all
different kinds of styles of writing and
so I'll step through some examples of
kind of
every type of corporal that that you can
come across the limitations of each one
unreliable grammar spelling syntax
punctuation so a lot of times depending
in this this often will have some some
importance on your mom what kind of
modeling techniques you use so for
example if your grammar is inconsistent
or incorrect
you know you'll be limited with sequence
models and you might rely or bleed more
heavily more into bag-of-words
approaches with spelling you know
there's certainly some commercially
available api's and the open source
tools you can use to correct spelling
but then there's also doing main
specific terminology where you have to
employ things like fuzzy matching and
stuff like that to correct spelling the
unique terminology so this is another
another constraint I've touched on this
already but basically this idea of okay
you know there's specific terms that are
unique to that company or you need to
administer you need to that product or
unique to that that company's customers
that need to be accounted for and so
basically you need to define those and
make sure you incorporate that knowledge
especially into your into your NLP
pipeline and then finally this idea of
training availability so basically this
limits the amount of additional labeled
data that you can get you already
started off with none to a limited
amount you know eventually you want to
you want to get more and more to see how
well you're bought your models are
testing but you know you have to be
cognizant that you know every training
iteration that you go through you have
to make it count this isn't this isn't a
lot of these organizations don't have
people who are sitting around just
waiting to test your models for you
especially because this knowledge is
very specific and you know very
expensive to acquire
so in terms of so these are some of the
challenges in terms in terms of how to
approach these these are these are a
couple these are a couple like to look
at so first is the machine learning
aspect and so with machine learning we
have some constraints with that said
really what you're trying to do with me
with your machine learning is a couple
things one as I said in the beginning
there isn't really a one-size-fits-all
solution you're gonna have a you know a
very wide range of variants and
distribution in terms of you know how
your corpus is structured so one of the
things you want to do is you want to add
a lot of flexibility into your NOP
pipeline and this isn't really anything
too crazy in terms of the modeling
approaches so you will you know like any
data science project you will try
multiple modeling approaches but what is
a little bit different about this is
your feature extraction so what's
happening here is that you actually
break apart your feature extraction and
you add multiple steps here and I'll go
through something I'll go through an
example of what this could look like but
basically there's basically you employ
modular programming and you're able to
switch out different functions to either
reduce noise or extract features or do
some kind of culmination of each one so
an example of what this could look like
and I'll walk through a few here but
just so what what just and this is one
of the more simple ones and I'll go
through a more complex one but one thing
you could do here is you have a text you
could you can reduce that text by just
removing stop words and this can be by
using the stop words dictionary and NLT
Kay or maybe you create your own then
you extract features so or sorry extract
entities and you can do this a couple
different ways you can use lookups in
this specific example you can use part
of speech tagging and write your own
custom grammar to pull out things like
noun phrases and this is again easy to
do in NLT Kay and then finally you go
through you know a modeling approach so
this can be something as simple as doing
a vector distance calculation between
the text and
a similar text vector within your corpus
so some more complicated examples and
this kind of ties back into
understanding or your your corpus so
technical reports are generally written
very well the grammar is very reliable
and part of that is because you you know
they're they're reviewed multiple times
and have have multiple authors so what
so one of the things you one things that
allows you to do is that it allows you
to extract some additional features that
you usually wouldn't be able to extract
so for example one of the things that in
this example is that you can do subject
predicate object triplets and based off
of that map those two an intent and now
you have an intent feature as well as
all the other features that you would
normally collect like entities and maybe
even some topics as well an example on
the right with a QA q and A's are you
know kind of opened for anyone to submit
to and you know generally aren't
reviewed spelling grammars it's pretty
off so things like grammar and spelling
are not as reliable and so you know
capturing things like intent are become
a lot more tricky and really what
happens is that you the more you have to
be very conservative in terms of what
you extract because you don't want to
lose any information from the text
that's there so in this case it might be
easier to just kind of whittle away at
the text and gradually iteratively
reduce the noise until you're left with
probably still a lot of noise but at
least less than you had before and then
map those to a topic model such as
something like LD a
so the second the second thing we that
we can do here in addition to some of
the machine learning approaches and
building this flexible pipeline with
different feature extraction methods is
adding to the ontology and the
dictionary of our NLP pipeline and so
with enterprises there are again
domain-specific companies specific
product specific and user specific terms
and these are terms that we need to
teach our NLP pipeline otherwise it's
not going to be able to extract some of
these terms so an example an example
term that I like to use is something
like SCC if you are a college football
fan SCC is going to be you know domain
specific to a football conference to you
whereas if you are you know more in
equities and investing SEC is going to
you know become its stands for
Securities Exchange Commission so again
there's there's some domain-specific
terms here that we that we want to add
to our NOP pipeline now the question is
how do you add these effectively because
no one really wants to sit there and
just pump out a dictionary that says
okay SCC equals this and this and this
and here are some of the other terms
that can also mean SEC well the answer
to that is that it depends and it
depends on really the size of your
corpus and and really how much effort
you can you're allowed to put in so one
of the ways that you can build these
dictionaries is kind of the manual way
or you have a domain expert sitting down
and you know and pump out these things
or you can use more statistical
approaches such as word embeddings which
I know we've gone over a couple times
with it's conference I'll go over in a
second but basically either way you need
to come you need to teach your NOP
pipeline to equate certain terms and
certain similarities and certain
relationships within each other so the
example I like to use is with iron and
Fe so Fe is the chemical symbol for iron
and if you were to try to equate those
in a dictionary well if you were to try
to equate those in general it would be
very hard to do just out of the box
about any kind of learning material so
for example you know if you wanted to do
something like fussy mashing it would be
very difficult to to match iron in Fe
with each other because they don't share
any of the same characters and they're
very you know relatively speaking very
different lengths now if you have a very
very large corpus that meant that has
multiple mentions of iron and Fe you can
use a more statistical approach like
word of beddings or if you don't it
might just be easier to just manually
create that yourself and then the final
approach here the third approach is
corpora understanding so corpora are
different within an enterprise these are
just three simple examples with you know
technical reports QA form and reference
manuals so some of the things that you
want to look at and that can vary
tremendously and this kind of goes back
to building a flexible pipeline is your
corpus size your lexical diversity and
your grammar and spelling so there's a
couple things here first you know
understanding your corpora is going to
be an iterative process you know machine
learning is about it's going to machine
learning is about progress not
perfection so the more that you iterate
the more progress you're going to make
and early on you can do you can do some
you know simple statistics that I
mentioned earlier like lexical diversity
and that kind of thing but ultimately
you're gonna learn more things about
your corpora as you build out your
pipeline and as you run the corpus
through your pipeline multiple times the
second thing about this underscore
understanding is that there's really
lots of possibilities lots of different
things you can do to understand this
there's a talk later today about yellow
break which has some great tools another
thing to do our word embeddings which
you can use then to map relationships
between entities you can do some and
these are again just some simple
examples we can do simple things like
frequency distribution and then also
some some topic modeling this is done
with LD a viz which is a an open source
library that you can use to kind of see
which words and which which words are
prevalent which is within certain topics
mm-hmm so overall this is kind of this
this is again kind of a general approach
so machine learning domain knowledge and
corporate understanding combining those
three one thing I do want to mention
with with training especially is that
because you have a limited number of
labeled data as you train basically your
machine learning models are going to
learn from your trainer and this is kind
of a lesson learned is that yeah I mean
machine learning models they learn from
whatever you teach it so if you were to
ask the machine learning algorithm hey
if all your friends jumped off a cliff
would you jump off a cliff
it would say yes it would and that's
really that's really the the lesson
learned here is that I've deployed this
deployers product before for other
companies and eventually you'll get to a
point where the trainer isn't exactly
sure what the answer should be and so
they'll start guessing and that actually
impacts the model in a negative way so
so it's kind of show kind of a lift that
you get with this approach this is with
a corpus with for the oil and gas
industry basically just employing a
single NOP pipeline f1 scores you know
not that impressive trying multiple
pipelines you get a you get a little bit
of lift in your f1 score and then
finally when you do that enhanced
feature extraction with adding those
custom dictionaries and adding multiple
you know modular programming with your
feature extraction you get you get that
lift so so what I want to do real quick
is it kind of just demonstrate a simple
example of this
so this is a this isn't this is one of
the NLP products this is a website
called refining online you can you it's
free you can go when you have to create
an account and so I'm just gonna type in
a simple question in in natural language
so I'll say how how to raise isobutylene
and what it's doing right now is it's
searching across the corpus to find
similar similar documents and so you can
see here that you know the answers that
it comes back with yes it you know yes
or some entity recognition there but one
of the other things that you can do and
these are actually drawn from technical
reports so like I say you can do some
more advanced feature extraction of
things like doing doing intent modeling
so even though I don't specifically say
even though I know the answers
explicitly say race it knows that I'm
trying to increase isobutylene and
that's kind of what that those are the
intents that are mapped within this
document so preserving isobutylene
increase isobutylene so forth and so and
you'll fill well for the sake of time
you know feel free to go in on your own
and play with that if you'd like okay so
anyway just kind of just kind of
summarizing things up so so some
additional challenges in your prize
especially considering that most don't
have annotated label data for you one
that there's really forward it that I
kind of want every kind of want to share
and that's you know there's minimal
labeled data minimal annotations
domain-specific terminology you know
huge huge range and grammar spelling
punctuation all that and then training
availability the trick to overcoming a
lot of these revolves around feature
extraction yes modeling is important but
if you don't know your feature
extraction then you're mulling becomes a
heck of a lot more difficult and then
also building just flexibility within
your NOP pipelines you know using
modular programming allowing you're
allowing yourself the flexibility to
handle all those different types of
authors with their own styles and
vocabularies and all that so anyway
that's all and I'll take questions now
[Applause]
so we've just got time for a one quick
question then we got a great talk thank
you how do you manage expectations with
the customer where oh just used
artificial intelligence or if Google can
do it why can't we or I gave you a big
computer why isn't this done already
yeah that's a good one
yeah I think there's certainly like a
lot of hype going around with AI in
managing customer expectations I think
the important thing is to try to partner
with them as much as you can I think
that the problem comes is when they put
all the responsibilities and all the
liability liability on you and so in
this specific example especially if
information retrieval I mean this is
machine learning and if you have good
trainers it will improve and so I I try
to let influence them to put some skin
in the game as well and to and to
basically have them take ownership
especially with it with a domain
knowledge and expertise that's required
to train something like this thank you
Jason